[Musik]
hallo herzfrequenz heute gibt eine
kleine idee zum muttertag ich werde
petit four wackendorff enormen slowup
klein sehr genau und zwar eine kleine
süße kleine törtchen aus der
französischen konditorei oder auch der
französische batterie um besser gesagt
und die sind wirklich super fürs
bestehen aus einem mitglied boden der
dann mit marmelade bestrichen wird gerne
auch mit einem likör getränkt und dann
werden sie einfach wunderschön verziert
und ich denke in so einer kleinen und
süßen geschenkbox sondern kleines schild
dran sind wirklich so verfügt vor allem
finde ich es auch eine relativ günstige
trifft weil man einfach nicht so viele
zutaten und keinen besonderen zweck
gebraucht
ich hab zwar ein paar ist pablo mit
drauf die eigentlich ganz nach dem motto
wenn die s-bahn blumen aber die müssen
ja nicht sein das weiß einfach nur so
noch mal eine schöne deko idee ich zeige
euch jetzt zuerst mal wie man die
betritt platte hersteller die geht auch
wirklich super schnell das meiste also
die meiste zeit geht eigentlich drauf um
die ganzen fans drauf zu setzen
ansonsten geht alles relativ schnell
also erstmal hier die zutaten für die
siegplatte für den betrieb braucht
spielzimmer war meier 50 etwas manila
extrakt mit riesen salz 80 gramm mehl
und 20 und stärker für den betrieb nehme
ich jetzt immer warm und schlagzeug mit
zucker salz und wasser extrakt etwa 45
minuten lang auf
[Musik]
so habe ich einfach keine klümpchen oder
zeigt wird noch ein bisschen feiern aber
eigentlich ist ja kein teig seine masse
wird es ganz locker und vorsichtig
untergehoben nehme ich hier meinen
eckigen back rahmungen auf mein pass
durch die folie einfach runter mit
ständig den markt kamen auch die
griechen stufe 1
du könntest auch ein ganz normales bugs
verwenden so wird einfach ein bisschen
gleichmäßiger und die ecken sind immer
schön gerade und dafür sich jetzt die
masse ein und streiche
[Musik]
wo kommt die bizkit platt rät in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 12 bis 15 minuten bis
platte habe ich nach dem backen muss
sofort mit einem messer auf das wort
herausgelöst und die partie jetzt
abkühlen lassen und jetzt werde ich sehe
stürzt und damit die ba folie wegziehen
kann
dafür lege ich jetzt einen bauplatz
geschirrtuch drauf das habe ich eben
auch beim abkühlen drauf klasse nicht
auftritt wird dann einen trotzdem retten
das ganze praktisch weg und die folie
abziehen
[Musik]
lauerbach folie bekommt übrigens ganz
einfach sauber wenn ihre zeitkarten
sowie die hier zum beispiel entweder auf
das ist aber mit metall ganz vorsichtig
und das ganze dann einfach weg steht
[Musik]
die reste können wir dann einfach unter
fließendem wasser oder in der
spülmaschine weg bekommen so jetzt habe
ich hier meine festplatte und für die
weiterverarbeitung brauche ich noch ein
paar zutaten wie zeige ich es tritt
dafür braucht es vier esslöffel
orangensaft oder ihr könnt auch ein
orangenlikör nehmen 150 gramm marmelade
gar nicht nur etwa neun monate ohne
stückchen vereinfacht wird 200 gramm
marzipanrohmasse und tun das computer zu
kommen nämlich zuerst einmal den saft
und tränke jetzt mit wurden damit
[Musik]
do
nämlich die erdbeer marmelade und dies
wie gesagt einfach ziert und ohne
stückchen und die habe ich gerade
einfach ein bisschen erwerben letzten
sich besser verstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich die teigplatten viertel
das heißt ich muss jetzt einfach ab und
teils in der hälfte jeweils durch einmal
so oder so
[Musik]
die
jetzt lege ich dir teigplatten ganz aus
übereinander
[Musik]
nützlich ist diese platte auf einen
treffer da kommt eine backform wird dann
klebt
[Musik]
die denken
ich bin
jetzt kann ich die marge von roma zu
nehmen und 4 den puderzucker 1
dadurch kann ich die masse später
einfach ein bisschen besser auf
[Musik]
durch
und hier nehme ich jetzt mal so viele
fotos ca das einfach nur schöne feste
masse entsteht die aber jetzt auch nicht
brüchig werden sollte also ich habe
jetzt etwas noch zwei und die last jetzt
einfach die benutzung auf wollen durch
die perfekten jetzt kann ich sie auf
rollen dafür nehme ich jetzt in dieser
zucker und werde jetzt die platte auch
die größe dieser bizkit platte ausrollen
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr da auch
diese zeit helfe das zunehmend dann wird
schön gleichmäßig oder ihr macht einfach
ohne
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die matte bahn decke
ausschneiden und war in etwa der größe
wie die bezirksklasse also 815
[Musik]
hier am rand wenn ziemlich ganz pass ist
nicht schlimm denn den rand schneidig
gleich weg jetzt nehme ich noch mal eine
folie oder ein backpapier nächste drauf
und einen zweiten toten red hats drauf
damit die platte einfach schön klappt
ist stelle ich sie so für etwa eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank und
eigentlich gleich weiter die biscuits
platte ist schon durchgeführt und auch
schöne lieben und jetzt mach ich den
puderzucker kommt jetzt dafür 150 g
zucker und da kommt etwas zitronensaft
rein passt dann auch geschmacklich sehr
gut dazu
[Musik]
zitronensaft dass ein flüchtiger kuss
entsteht
[Musik]
während ein lasse ich jetzt weiß und
einen teil selbst leicht rosa 1 und
staffel nämlich jetzt ein bisschen
lebensmittel verpasst da brauche ich
dann auch nur ein paar tropfen dafür
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich mich um die
businessklasse kümmern und da werde ich
jetzt 3,5 x 35 cm große würfel zu
schneiden
[Musik]
die
houston
beim schneiden habe ich einen tipp für
euch und zwar rückt zuerst einmal nur
die marke parkfläche 1
dann wird das schneiden nämlich ein
bisschen einfacher das heißt erst mal
längs und quer die marzipan decke und
dann schneide ich komplett durch
[Musik]
hier frage ich die partie vor hier auf
ein abgelegter gesetzt neben einen roten
retter und tritt im ganz leicht drauf so
werden sie noch mal schön glatt und
jetzt kommt der treppe runter falls das
unter tropft mit nehme ich den großen
streichen auf die oberfläche und lassen
hier am rand zum mieten runter laufen
das fände ich ganz schön
[Musik]
für die deka hier ein bisschen was
hergestellt und zwar habe ich erst bahre
zuckerperlen und kleinen herzchen und
habe sogar essbare blüten gefunden die
ganze bei uns in globo sind auf dem
gemüseabteilung aber ihr könnt doch
einfach mal zum beispiel im blumenladen
nachfragen sie sollten sich auf jeden
fall nicht gespritzt sein und gesetze
ich jetzt hier auch für walter gross
noch leben
[Musik]
mit
gefühlt
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch die
zeitschrift nehmen die gibt in
verschiedenen farben und könnte auch
damit die kleinen kerzen verzieren
[Musik]
juli
jetzt in die partie vor fertig und ihr
könnt sie zu lassen wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr selber auch in muffin förmchen
setzen dann ist es verteilen und
funktionieren und verschenken natürlich
auch einfacher und auch anschließend das
essen denn dann kann man direkt auf den
muffin förmchen heraus essen
[Musik]
ich hab jetzt die kleinen häppchen in so
eine kleine geschenkbox gesetzt wird
wirklich zu süß aus kann man als
abdeckung unter mamas schenken sich die
kritik als geschenk selbst gemacht wenn
ich auch aus unrichtige eignet so genau
worauf man achten sollte darf man die
partie fuhr einfach weiter
biscuit bestehen nicht so lange offen
herumstehen lässt weil sie dann einfach
schnell trocknen
das heißt immer schön abdecken und auch
beim verpacken zugleich eine folie
dazwischen dass er nicht trocken werden
und dann verschenken und am besten
frisch verzehren dann muss ich diese
tags mit ihrem genauen kraft ist bis
heute zu essen ihk es auf der hand essen
jetzt mal so so sieht übrigens aus
locker man kann ja auch geschmacklich
total variieren kann auch okay aber kann
auch zum beispiel mit spears' chilli
machen mit aprikosen konfitüre man kann
einen dunklen teig backen oder auf zwei
platten der held unter den augen zu
sehen kein problem keiner tätig alle
rannten
man kann auch bis mitte mit seinen
pferden machen mit lemon gehört also
wirklich ganz viele verschiedene
variationen lippe heute eher so ein
kunstkonzept finde ich und auch so eine
kleine mutter taktik hat mir möchte
mache es gerne mehrere variationen
solisten der blume vorstellen
endlich mal wieder flohen tauchen wir
ganz genau weiß wie wenig bewusst wahr
ist ja einfach auch erheblich auf der
blume
ich kenne es aber von früher mein papa
hat mit mir immer ringelblume gegessen
wir hatten wir bei uns im garten und die
wurde halt irgendwann haben wir die
anzahl machte die firma thema geschimpft
meine stellung flogen
wahrscheinlich so viele blumen gegessen
falls ihr dieses rezept auch nach machen
wollt dann geht auf meinem blog auf
belize - blog schreibt mir falls ihr
euch mehr variation und wünscht von
petit four auch mal andere deko ideen
und geschmacksrichtungen dann mach ich
dir gerne für euch noch mal nach oder
hat eben vor und er machte damals und
ich wünsche euch jetzt mal ganz viel
spaß dabei ich wünsche auch jetzt schon
mal alle mit an einen schönen muttertag
und es wirklich eine wunderhübsche
geschenke über die ich mich auch sehr
freuen wäre das einfach machen
[Musik]
youtube